Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello.
Hi.
I'm nervous.
I choose karaoke streams to make me less nervous sometimes, but then also the karaoke stream itself makes me nervous.
This is a dollar for every night that I've listened to you sing, Harvest Moon.
Should I sing it tonight as well, even though it's not the Harvest Moon?
Today, I've chosen a little bit more of a chilly vibe.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Remember that time you did karaoke to calm your nerves before Big Dana worked out like that?
actually I know but I get nervous for the karaoke too I
might lose service by the time you start but me too is cool I don't know if you're still here hello what's I gonna do oh I was gonna do this I'm
gonna eat a throat drop not drop Is this open?
A cough, not a cough drop.
This one's open.
I have so many things for my throat.
Thank you so much for the 50 gift and thank you!
Hello everybody, welcome in.
Karaoke!
Let me just, uh...
Let me...
just i don't know why i get so nervous it's also because like also today i have no plan i have no plan and
i'm just i'm just we're just winging it remember to drink lots of water and tea huh i am i got a big little give big big cupa big cupa right next to me about Densetsu.TXU tomorrow.
I have to warn my bank!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Invisible Moose, thank you so much for the 20 here today, Kube.
It's weird.
things like this are so strange.
Like, planning stuff.
It's always like, and this doesn't just go for, like, VTubers, but, like, Oh my gosh, Dermatio, thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you!
Oh, that's right.
Oh, chat froze.
Why does it keep happening?
And freeze!
There we go.
Oh, wrong chat.
Oh my gosh, I just realized.
I think it's the... I think I was practicing.
I think that is the debut chat.
That's so funny.
Oops.
I just didn't even question... Ah, there you guys are.
I didn't even question it.
oopsie but um you know when you're like this is like for projects for anything you know you like spend all this time prepping and all this time stressing and all this time preparing and then as soon as it comes it's over in like you know for me it'll be over in an hour and it's like all this and for me it's also weird because like
Phoebe's changing a couple things Vicky is straight up debuting but for me not much is changing so I'm like why am I
nervous not much is really changing for me I guess you know the sound of saying debut or it's like the start of something new in a sense because it's the start of the three of us together but
but in terms of like streaming and stuff nothing's gonna change you're gonna make a lot of fans pregnant tomorrow tomorrow why i'm seeing sweet caroline sweet caroline
It happens.
You are about to start a new journey.
I guess that's kind of true.
That is kind of true.
Not kind of.
It is true.
I mean, it is the start of something new.
We're gonna do our best with it.
You're nervous because it's going to be awesome!
And you're always nervous before awesome things.
I...
You know, I have a few new things prepared.
A few new things to kind of make it a little bit shinier.
For the most part, I didn't want to make it seem all new, because, you know, like I said, for the most part, things will be staying the same.
So, make today a graduation stream.
No!
You guys would kill me!
I'm already dead!
And you would be like...
You would be like...
But, um...
Yeah, where's the white background and the smiling and the slight breeze in my hair?
And our little hearts.
I don't even want to joke about stuff like that, so.
Excited for it.
Have fun.
Yeah, we'll just have fun.
Minto karaoke before Denza 2.exe.
You're spoiling us.
MVP.
Yeah, MVP.
Please know.
No, no, no, I'm not.
Densetsu.exe, does that make...
Densu.exe, does that make...
Mint the ghost in the machine?
Ah!
The shorts you guys have been releasing and build up to tomorrow's debut had me dying of laughter.
A lot of the shorts, basically...
Oh my gosh.
I feel like we should release an extended cut or something because the shorts are all basically...
Most of them are taken from one...
session.
The three of us kind of met up and then just like talked for like an hour or something.
Minto was always an idol, but soon more will know.
I don't know.
Yeah, a lot of stuff was cut out.
Um, it felt like a podcast.
Yeah, we were just like, we were just chatting about everything and anything.
We were just like,
Oh!
Oh my gosh, before I start singing, can I show you guys something?
I can finally show you this, which is kind of crazy.
Hold on.
I can finally maybe satisfy some curious folks.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for all the super chats, you guys.
Thank you, Shiny Dears.
I should start writing things down, huh?
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Release the Minto cut.
Thank you so much.
Okay, hold on.
Not the wet wang.
so there was a collab bond
yes okay all right here we go this might look familiar to some of you all hopefully all of you so i hope all of you watch this oh wait hold on whoa familiar familiar right some of you might have i saw a few comments some people noticed that there was a point of silence.
Oh my god.
Spooked, man.
Oh, nope.
Not yet.
Wait, there we go.
I can satisfy all your curiosity.
I actually had to censor that, or I had to silence that manually.
Once again, changed locations and I got to sing with my favorite girlies.
ever phoebe and vicky thank you guys did the two exe yeah that's it i
was like we were stressing actually we were high key stressing we were like they were like you have to cut the song and i was like i can't cut the song and so ultimately it i felt so terrible ultimately it it made it so that vicky would like like and everything early,
like, it was, it was, it was, we were like, what do we do?
What do we do?
Because we were like, do we keep it a secret?
Like, super secret until, until everything do, we had to, all because of that.
Literally all because of the song.
And then I was like, well, I can't cut the MC afterwards.
Like, it wouldn't make sense.
But then I don't know.
So.
We kind of figured out, as you see what happened, that's kind of how we decided to do it.
Yeah, I'm so sorry, Vicky.
I think she was okay with it, though.
I think she had a lot of fun making all of her videos and everything.
Calling Din Setsu Da Ixia 3A.
I'm not clickbait.
Where can I see that cover?
That's a great question.
You can see that cover in my 3D debut.
live stream oh hi vicky wait let me let me let me put you here so i can see you there we go save i was happy to be in the concert no matter what yeah and thank you for being there that day too i really appreciate it like supporting me throughout the show too you know and everything in
it oh wait oh my gosh vicky i bought something else okay Like, you guys, I...
I got Vicky a Shadow the Hedgehog.
Hold on, let me look at that.
It's like a stretchy Shadow the Hedgehog.
I was like, I bought this for you.
And then she was like, oh my gosh, I've seen these before on TikTok.
People will cut off his limbs and then fill it with water and watch him expand.
And I was like, but also, Vicky, I went to the Lego store recently and I got you a little Lego...
I got you a little Lego shadow.
yeah don't google shadow inflation let's go yeah oh my gosh you guys have to see vicky's debut tomorrow not just because she's so stinking cute but oh my gosh it's so good oh it's so good thank you my I got you!
I got you!
Do not Google shadow inflation.
I wonder what you would get.
Maybe you'll get the TikTok video.
Just dig around a little bit.
Membership placeholder for Vicky Roman.
Idol.
Yeah!
Do you really wonder?
Maybe.
Gotta go prep for debut.
Yeah!
See you later.
See you, see you, see you.
See you, see you, see you tomorrow.
See you tomorrow.
I don't want to dig around.
Victoria Roman.
Oh my gosh, I want to sing our new song.
I want to sing like, I wonder actually though if I could sing like the, I wonder if it's like a type of song where you could sing the full version.
Time to learn I am all of me from Shem.
on that talk i think she i think vicky's got that covered i've been so excited for densetsu.exe and vicky yeah since the three-part harmony you guys didn't have a music box of fate yeah yeah yeah yeah so oh yeah the song also our song i you could hear it too i'm so excited oh my gosh i'm so excited for you guys to hear the full version of the song because I really love the chorus but it didn't show my favorite part in the preview obviously we can't save we can't show you the best part for the preview but okay what should I sing what should I sing what should I say oh let's sing let's just no I don't want to sing this one we'll sing sweet Caroline bread bread
week Caroline since someone asked for earlier.
I'm not, oh wait, I'm not like, uh, I am doing requests, but not like a formal requests thing.
It's kind of just, kind of, just, we're just going to go with the flow of that's okay, you guys.
Kind of, kind of just doing whatever I want.
Just doing whatever I want.
If that's all right, if that's all right.
Okie dokie I wish
I knew the Hugh Jackman version Where it began I can't begin to know when But then I know it's growing strong When it was the spring.
And spring became the summer.
Who'd I believe you'd come along?
Touching hands.
Reaching out.
Touching me.
Touching you.
Sweet Caroline.
Breadbread.
The times never seem so good, so good, so good!
I've been inclined, bread, bread, bread To believe they never would, but Look at the night And it don't seem so lonely We fill it up with only two the bread thing after sorry and when i hurt hurting runs off my shoulders how can i hurt when holding you warm touching warm reaching out touching me Keep touching you.
Sweet Caroline.
Bread, bread, bread.
Good times never seem so good.
So good.
I've been inclined to believe they never would.
Oh, no.
Oh my gosh.
I wonder if we could even find karaoke versions a lot.
Sweet Caroline, ba ba ba, the dance never seems so good.
So good!
And go!
Sweet Caroline, I believe they never could.
Caroline The dance never seemed so good So good, yeah
I forgot to ask How was the audio?
How was the sound on that?
I was just like using it as a test song And I got so into it I forgot to test if it was too loud or not
It was good?
Okay, good, good, good Okay, so Hugh Jackman played he's he is in a maybe it's released now i don't know an upcoming maybe question mark movie about neil diamond or a guy no a guy that played an impersonator of neil diamond i'm so confused the song was the song my family sang my grandma for her birthday oh so sweet huge jacked man name.
Yeah.
And Hugh Jackman played the guy.
Oh, gosh.
Jean, Jean, Jean, Jean, Jean Valjean in Le Maze.
And, and the way he sings is very, like, specific.
Jean Valjean.
Yeah, Jean Valjean.
And, oh, prisoner six, two, eight, oh, one.
why should we sing some lemmas but um so because Hugh Jackman has this very specific way of singing and he sings sweet Caroline he's like sweet Caroline and there's like this guy who sorry this is like the most convoluted explanation ever but there's this guy who does like parody videos of Hugh of like like pretending or acting like he's or singing like how Hugh Jackman sings and then replaces the lyrics to songs with bread because that's what happened in Le Messe is Jean Valjean got arrested because he stole a loaf of bread and so as a bass singer that song is like what do I go to it's really it's like such a hype song everybody knows sweet Caroline
And he's like, I stole a loaf of bread.
It's so funny.
The way he sings is so specific.
I stole a loaf of bread.
Okay, oh gosh, my brain rot is very multi-layered.
Yes, yes, indeed.
Francis Hardcore, man.
I don't know.
Do you hear the purple sing?
Singing the song.
What is that one?
I don't even know.
I could sing.
What is a L'Ameselable song?
Um.
Song of Angry Bread.
Sing on my own.
Okay.
I'll sing.
that wait that's such a it's i feel like it matches the vibes of my sad winter setup
and now i'm all alone again nowhere to turn no one to go to without a hope without a friend without a face to say hello to but now the night is near now i can make wait oh gosh sometimes i walk alone at night when everybody else is sleeping i think of him and then i'm happy with the company wait what's the what's the note here the city goes to bed and i can live inside my head
on my own pretending he beside me all alone I walk with him till morning without him I feel his arms around me and when I close wait let's wait I've said the wrong word in the rain the pavement shines like silver all the lights are misty in the river in the darkness the trees are full of starlight and all I see is him and me forever and forever and I I know it's only in my mind that I'm talking to myself and not to him.
And although I know that he is blind, still I say there's a way for us.
I love him, but when the night is over He is gone, the river is just a river Without him, the world around me changes The trees are barren everywhere, the streets are full of strangers I love him, but every day I'm learning All my life, I've only been pretending Without me,
his world will go on turning A world that's full of happiness that I have never known
I love him I love him Solid snake I love snake But only on...
The self-insert.
Yeah, sorry.
Got a little carried away there.
Let me... I also realized I forgot to turn off...
I haven't heard one, but I forgot to turn off sounds for the doughnuts.
So let me...
Do that real quickly.
One moment.
I don't even know if one has shown up or not.
I don't know if they're like buried beneath a bunch of stuff.
Minto sounds like a princess?
I do.
Thank you.
Wicked?
Oh, don't even.
Oh my gosh, wait.
My wicked brain right, though.
for it now which wicked song which wicked song be nice if they made a mute all toggle i know right i feel like at this point they could but okay save and then i have to remember what because they're not all the same volume save save save popular i love popular we could do multiple oh my gosh a of people saying popular okay i'll do popular popular uh oh wait do i do the ariana grande version or the christian chenoweth version um
i'm more familiar with the original so i'll do that version whenever i see someone less fortunate than i and let's face it who is Less fortunate than I, my tender heart tends to start to bleed.
And when someone needs a makeover, I simply have to take over.
I know, I know exactly what they need.
And even in your case, though it's the toughest case I've yet to face, Don't worry, I'm determined to succeed.
Follow my lead And yes, indeed, you will be popular You're gonna be popular I'll teach you the proper poise when you talk to boys Little ways to flirt and flounce I'll show you what shoes to wear How to fix your hair Everything that really counts to be popular I'll help you be popular.
You'll hang with the right cohorts.
You'll be good at sports.
Know the slang you've got to know.
So let's start because you've got an awfully long way to go.
Don't be offended by my frank analysis.
Think of it as personality dialysis.
Now that I've chosen to become a palisester and advisor, there's nobody wiser.
Not when it comes to popular.
And with an assist from me to be who you'll be Instead of dreary who you were, well, are There's nothing that can stop you from becoming popular LAR La la la We're gonna make you popular When I see depressing creatures With unprepossessing features remind them on their own we have to think of celebrated heads of state or especially great communicators did they have brains or knowledge don't make me laugh they were popular right that's my favorite part of the movie version it's not about aptitude it's the way you're viewed so it's very shrewd to be very very popular like me Oh my gosh,
my Miss Alphaba.
Look at you.
You're beautiful.
Oh, whoa.
I have to go.
There's a lady here.
Oh my gosh.
You're welcome.
And though you protest your disinterest, I know clandestinely.
You're gonna grin and bury your newfound popularity.
La, la, la, you'll be popular.
Just not quite as popular as me.
I forgot to turn on reverb.
Oh my god.
Woman jump scare, woman jump scare.
That's another wicked song.
I forgot to warm up for today's stream, so I apologize in advance.
My favorite part of karaoke streams is seeing all the great names go, Make it sing!
No!
Is that Glinda?
Look, it's Glinda!
Denny, the reverb?
Thank you.
That's not true.
What a wicked karaoke.
Defying gravity?
Galinda Galinda Look it's Galinda Let's see I can try Defying Gravity I can't Should I I guess the music or the musical version is like what makes the sorry wait I'm I have a million thoughts right now What is the difference between the film?
Because it's so much longer.
It's like seven and a half minutes long.
Go, Linda.
Go for it.
Thank you so much for the mic, Kat, and thank you.
I want to hear her sing that note.
The dialogue.
I can, let's see, let's see.
I might have to do both parts.
Oh, gosh.
Elphaba, why couldn't you have stayed calm for once, instead of flying off the handle?
I hope you're happy, I hope you're happy now, I hope you're happy how you hurt your cause forever, I hope you think you're clever, I hope you're happy, I hope you're happy too, I hope you're proud how you would grovel in submission to feed your own ambition,
so though I can't imagine how,
right now.
I had to add a voice.
Elfie, listen to me.
Just say you're sorry.
You can still be with the wizard, what you've worked and waited for.
You can have all you ever wanted.
I know.
But I don't want it.
I thought there was a cat in my room.
I can't want it anymore.
Oh, I was early, sorry.
Hold on.
My gravity.
Something has changed within me.
The pacing is all different.
It's not what I'm used to.
something is not the same I'm through with playing by the rules of someone else's game too late for second guessing too late to go back to sleep it's time to trust my instincts close my eyes it's good and then one and leave it's time to try defying gravity I think I'll try defying gravity and you can't pull me down can't I make you understand you're having delusions of grandeur I'm through accepting limits it's slower Someone says they're so Some things I cannot change But till I try I'll never know Too long I've been afraid of Losing love I guess I've lost Well if that's love It comes at much too high a cost I'd sooner buy Defying gravity Kiss me good Oh boy,
I'm defying gravity And you can't pull me down This is, this is hard Why is it so slow?
Think of what we could do together Unlimited Together we're unlimited Together we'll be the greatest team there's ever been dreams the way we plan them if we work in tandem there's no fight we cannot win just you and I defying gravity with you and I defying gravity they'll never shut up they'll bring us down I couldn't remember whose harmonies I was doing.
Are you coming?
Well, are you guys?
Are you guys?
Are you coming?
I hope you're happy.
What is the note here?
Now that you're choosing this, you too.
I hope it brings you bliss.
I really hope you get it and you don't live to regret it.
I hope you're happy in the end I hope you're happy, my friend No, let her alone!
She hasn't done anything wrong!
I'm the one you want!
This part's gonna make me laugh!
It's me!
Me?
So if you care to find me, let the
one deserve the chance to fly.
And if I'm flying solo, at least I'm flying free.
To those who'd ground me, take a message back from me.
Tell them how I'm defying gravity.
I am defying the revenue And soon I'll match them in renown
I am not suited for Elfaba I'm more suited for Glinda, I think Unlimited
Unlimited Unlimited
Oh, nobody in all of us know wizard that there is or was is ever gonna bring me
down.
Did you guys ever see the commercials of Cynthia Arrivo being like, No, that's my line.
But people would like slow it down.
They'd be like, no, that's my line.
That's all I can think of.
Tarsan.
Oh, gosh.
Hello, by Adele.
The original singer is one of the highest vocal raids on Broadway.
Oh, Adina Madel, she's, like, insane.
That lady.
Sorry, I was, like, laughing.
I was, like, laughing, like, half the song.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, gosh.
I'm still nervous, so it's like...
Oh, gosh, okay.
Oh, my God.
much for the 30 gifts and thank you thank you guys so much brother super chance thank you we played your karaoke of golden hour at our wedding what
but first of all congratulations but
oh my gosh
wow thank you
Okay, what should I sing next?
I kind of want to sing Disney.
Oh, wait.
I think I know what I want to sing.
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
I have to make sure it's the right one.
One second.
Okay, okay.
I think so.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Hold on, hold on.
I'm double checking.
Okay, wait.
Did I...
Did I miss it?
Okay.
I got it.
Evermore!
I'll sing that one after.
Actually, maybe I should sing it first.
Can we play your song at our wedding?
Really?
Yeah, I mean, sure.
If you want, I feel like you should get a hire a professional okay here we go
who's the leader of the club that's made for you and me m-i-c-k-e-y m-o-u-a-c hey there hi there hold there you're as welcome as can be m-i-c-k-e-y m-o-u-s-c Mickey Mouse!
Micky Mouse!
Forever than a solar banner high, high, high, high!
Come along and sing your song and join the Jam Marine.
M-I-C-K-E-Y, M-O-U-S-E.
Mickey Mouse Club, Mickey Mouse Club.
We'll have fun.
We'll meet new faces.
We'll do things and we'll go places.
All around the world we're marching.
Who's the leader of the club that's made for you and me?
M-I-C-K-E-Y, M-O-U-S-E Hey there, hi there, home there, you're as welcome as can be M-I-C-K-E-Y, M-O-U-S-E, Mickey Mouse Hello Jack!
Mickey Mouse!
Hello Jack!
Forever let us hold our banner high, high, high, high Come along and sing your song and join the jamboree M-I-C-K-E-Y, M-O-E-M-O-E-M-O-Y Hey Becky!
The cold children.
Now it's time to say goodbye to all our humble...
M-I-C.
See you real soon!
Tell me why.
Why because we like you.
M-O-U-S-E.
The ending is so scary.
It's like the...
Why is it such a cursed song?
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'll sing evermore.
Wait, which is the right version?
I don't remember.
I think it's the right version.
I don't think I have to change the...
I always think this.
I'm like, do I have to change the pitch?
The key.
I only wanted to sing the Donald Duck.
I was the one who had it all.
I was the master of my fate.
I never needed anybody in my life.
I learned the truth too late.
I'll never shake away the pain.
I close my eyes but she's still there.
I let her steal into my melancholy heart.
It's more than I can bear.
But now I know she'll never leave.
me even as she runs away she will still torment me call me hurt me move me come what may wasting in my lonely tower waiting by an open door I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in And be with me forevermore I rage against the trials of love I curse the fading of the light Though she's already flown so far beyond my reach She's never out of sight Now I know she'll never leave me Even as she fades from view She will still inspire me Be a part of everything I do Wasting in my lonely tower Waiting by an open door How full myself she'll walk right in And as the long,
long nights begin I'll think of all that might have been Waiting here forever
My lung capacity
Evermore.
Yippee!
All I ask of you are...
Twilight!
Wait, what's all I ask of you?
Wait.
I feel like I know that one.
Oh!
Phantom?
Oh, geez.
Getting all the...
The toughies, huh?
It's not easy being green.
I don't know that song.
Everything's alright from To The Moon.
I didn't learn it yet.
A rainbow connection?
Wait, oh my gosh.
This song is so sweet.
Wait, can I do it as Kermit?
Do I remember this song?
Why are there so many songs about rainbows and what's on the other side?
Rainbows are visions but only illusions and rainbows have nothing to hide.
So we've been told and some choose to believe it.
I know they're wrong, wait and see.
Someday we'll find it.
The rainbow connection.
The lovers, the dreamers, and the frogberg.
Who said every wish is true?
Would be heard and answered When wished on the morning star Somebody thought of that And someone believed it Look what it's done so far What's so amazing That keeps us stargazing think we might see someday we'll find it the rainbow connection the lovers the dreamers and me
i don't know this part wait oh my god have you been half asleep or have you heard voices.
I've heard them calling my name.
Is this the sweet sound that calls the young sailors?
The voice might be one and the same.
I've heard it too many times to ignore it.
It's something that I'm supposed to someday we'll find it the rainbow connection the lovers the dreamers and me
it's not kermit that was kermit the frog actually i have a secret that wasn't kermit the frog that was frog burt and and he sounds just like kermit a return from no service house let's go literally anything bruno mars that's a bruno mars song i don't think i've ever sung a bruno mars besides die with a smile but have i sung this one wait can i sing this one
She never fails to impress.
Really?
Were you impressed?
Hold on, wait.
Do I know this song?
Game Start!
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
Kissy face, kissy face.
Send to your phone, but I'm trying to kiss your lips for real.
Uh-huh.
Red hearts, red hearts.
That's what I'm on, yeah.
Come give me something I can feel.
Don't you want me like I want you, baby?
Meet me like I need you now Sleep tomorrow but tonight go crazy All you gotta do is just meet me at the Apochoo, Apochoo, Apochoo, Apochoo Apochoo, Apochoo, Apochoo, Apochoo, Apochoo, Apochoo Apochoo, Apochoo, Apochoo, Apochoo, uh-huh It's whatever, it's whatever,
it's whatever you like Hold that for the boys!
Turn this apote into a club
the girl what's up don't you want me like i want you baby don't you need me like i need you now sleep tomorrow but tonight go crazy all you gotta do is just meet me at the uh
So now you know the game.
Are you ready?
I'm coming to get ya.
Get ya, get ya.
Hold on, on.
I'm on my way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm on my way.
Don't you want me like I want you, baby?
Don't you need me like I need you now?
Sleep tomorrow but tonight go crazy.
All you gotta do is just meet me at the Apochu, Apochu, Apochu, Apochu, Apochu, Apochu, Apochu.
Just meet me at the Apochu, Apochu, Apochu, Apochu, Apochu, Apochu,
I don't know that song well enough
whatever it's all for fun anyway today hold on I want to listen to it how what is what is Rose is it Rose or Hold on, does she do the, what's it called, the harmony here?
Oh, she does.
Oh, that's what I was missing.
Rose.
Sorry, I was.
Oh, she does sing it.
Wait, maybe I should sing Bruno Mars' part then.
Maybe I should sing Bruno Mars' part then.
whatever it's fine oh let's see what else um wait I kind of want to sing Lever is that okay real quick a little break a little break with him Lever crying I'm not sure if it's from laughter or how pretty you sang Rainbow Connection blue I forgot to say earlier thank you so much for the for the for the spooky don't know I will sing I'll do a Christmas Where,
Christmas karaoke where I sing the Nijikon song.
Oh my gosh, Lazy Town!
Let's see.
I don't think I've sung this Lavey song before, so I wanted to sing it, if that's okay.
Moved out to a new city, June is dawning down on me, and all that I can see.
Sickly romance in the air.
Lovers stroller.
Wait, stroller?
Where can I start over?
I didn't mean to say stroller.
Like, they're a baby.
Can I start over?
Sorry.
Moved out to a new city.
June is dawning down on me and all.
A sickly romance in the air.
Love or stroll without a care inside Ooh, this can't be right Cause the sun's engaged to the sky And my best friends found a new guy I'm only getting older I've never had a shoulder to cry On someone to call mine Everybody's falling in love and I'm falling behind
Touch the ocean, fell right in Stepped outside and burned my skin My life won't go
Barsanova in my room Hope that I'll find someone too to love Because The sun's engaged in the sky And my best friends found a new guy I'm only getting older I've never had a shoulder to cry On someone to combine Everybody's falling in love And I'm falling behind Everybody's falling in love Everybody's falling in love
Everybody's falling in love Me
One, two, three
Yay!
Okay, I didn't mess up the second time But it was really hard to not To not laugh
Yay, yay, yay.
Stroller.
Don't say it.
Don't say it!
I wonder what else.
What other levee?
I haven't done this one.
Actually, I haven't done a lot of these.
Oh.
Mintney Spears, maybe.
thought about that song earlier snow white that's literally the song i was hovering over oh my gosh i'll try it i'll try it i've never sung about this one i'm gonna do with reverb though this is a sad song
can't help but notice
waves in which i failed myself i failed the world all the say I don't think I'm pretty it's not up for debate a woman's best currencies her body not her brain they try to tell me tell me I'm wrong But mirrors tell lies to me, my mind just plays along.
The world is a sick place, at least for a girl.
The people want beauty, skinny always wins, and I don't have enough of it.
of it
Sometimes I see her She looks like snow white She's everything I am But my wrongs are turned to rights Her body is smaller skin is so fair she's achieved everything I've dreamed of and it's all that I can think of they try to tell me tell me I'm wrong but mirrors tell lies to me my mind long the world is a sick place at least for a girl the people want beauty skinny always wins and i don't have enough of it i'll never have of it This song
is so sad.
Levi, are you okay?
Let's do a happy song next.
What's a happy song?
Ah,
DK rep.
So true.
Oh yeah, it didn't say Twilight, right, earlier?
Wait, I think I have to, like, adjust that song to...
Oh, was it...
Electric...
Light?
Was it taken down?
Oh my gosh, I don't see it anymore.
Oh no, there it is, just kidding.
Ha ha ha.
Dancing in my mind The early dawn, the shades of time Twilight crawling through my window pane Am I awake or do I dream The strangest pictures I have seen Night is day and twilight's gone away With your head held high and your scarlet lies She came down to me from the open skies It's either real or it's a dream There's something that is in between Twilight,
I only meant to stay a while Twilight, I gave you time to steal my mind away from me
Across the night I saw your face, face You disappear without a trace Trace, you brought me here But can you take me back?
Inside the image of your life Now that, now that it's day You hurt my dyslexia You let me hear And then you go away Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum It's a dream, there's nothing that is in between Twilight
Twilight To steal my mind Away from me I always, this song is such an otaku song, right?
I'm not the only one that thinks that, right?
You brought me here, but can you take me back again?
With your head held high You're scarlet flies, you came down to me from the open skies It's either real or it's a dream, there's nothing that is in between Twilight, I only meant to stay a while Twilight, I gave you time to steal my mind Bye-bye Twilight,
I only meant to stay a while I only meant to stay a while I only meant to stay a while Yeah!
You guys know!
I can't tell you how many times I watched that Daikon video Like an insane amount of time
It's so good Reminds me of simpler times Reminds me of all the good times, man.
Oh my gosh, watching the Densetsu video makes me want to sing something like kind of Nico Nico.
And that song also makes me want to sing kind of Nico Nico.
Opportunity Nicholas Lourdes!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
An encapsulation of pop culture from that time, right?
flower face i think you'd love her music oh write it down same vibes as levi okay i don't know it i'll look it up thank you now my neighbors know about taco music what's a do you know linger by the cranberries killy oh my gosh wait killy killy joker i almost sang that song for my 3d that's crazy I almost...
Why did I switch?
I don't remember.
I almost sang that one, though.
Linger.
I think I...
I know that one.
I'm pretty sure.
I think so.
I might get some of it wrong.
I'm sorry.
I'm writing some more songs down.
Bye.
If you, if you could return Don't let it burn, don't let it fade I'm sure I'm not being rude, but it's just your attitude It's tearing me apart It's ruining everything and I and I swore I swore I would be true
So why were you holding her hand?
Is that the way we stand?
Were you lying all the time?
Was it just a game to you?
But I'm in so deep You know I'm such a fool for you You got me wrapped around your finger do you have to let it linger do you have to do you have to do you have to let it linger oh i thought the world of you i thought nothing could wait go wrong but i was wrong wait i didn't remember this part i'm sorry
If you could get by trying not to lie Things wouldn't be so confused And I wouldn't feel so used But you always really knew I just wanna be with you And I'm in so deep You know I'm such a fool for you You got me wrapped around your feet Do you have to let it linger?
Do you have to?
Do you have to let it linger?
But I'm in so deep, you know I'm such a fool for you.
You got me wrapped around your finger.
Do you have to, let it linger?
Do you have to, do you have to, do you have to, let it linger?
You know I'm such a fool for you You got me wrapped around your finger Do you have to, let it linger?
Do you have to, do you have to, do you have to, do you have to let it linger?
I know what I'm going to sing next.
Oh, wait, which one was it?
Was it this one?
Wait, which one was it?
Is it this one?
Don't remember.
I think so.
I'll
be closer.
what I have to say Just
like children we sleep in We could dream this night away
But there's a full moon rising Let's go dancing in the night Where
the music's playing Let's go out and feel that night
Because I'm still in love with you I wanna see you dance again Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest moon And
we were strangers I have watched you from afar Now
it's getting late
I want to celebrate See it shining in your life Because
I'm still in love with you I want to see you dance again Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest moon So
much for the best he gets in the text!
Because I'm still in love with you I want to see you dance again Because I'm still in love with you On this harvest moon
We'll get all these similar ones out of the way Similar vibes
Oh my gosh, groove and magic I heard this song recently Over the county And I drive the main road Searching in the sun for another overlord I hear you singing in the wire I can hear you through the wire And the witch's alignment Is still on the line
I know I need a small vacation But it don't look like rain And if it snows that stretch down south Won't ever stand the strain And I need you more than want you And I want you for all time And the wizard's alignment Is still on the line
And I need you more than want you And I want you for all time And the witch in alignment
It's still on the line.
Hey, thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
That was a witch-taught lineman.
Wait, that was like a back-to-back.
Wait, what was I, what did I, I did a back-to-back?
Linger, harvest moon, witch-taught lineman.
I realized, I think tomorrow I'm gonna save the Nico Nico songs.
I have, I wanna sing a couple songs tomorrow so I think I'll save it for them and I already picked out what songs I want to sing so they're two very like Otaku songs that I have that I want to sing so I'll save it for tomorrow Killy Killy Joker though so I remember that well enough I didn't like learn it learn it because I you know I know the chorus for sure
It's so hard, John.
Wait, Killie Joker.
It's thinking Kanon Wakushima, so it's like...
She has a wait, what's the other song?
Oh, that's...
Hi, Miss Alice.
Anna.
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
Ba-da.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Wait, Killie, Killie Joker.
Is there an instrumental, let's say?
There is.
I don't think I can sing it, though.
Not today.
Tomorrow's my birthday!
I should have a happy early birthday, happy early birthday!
I think I could do Still Doll, though.
I think I remember it, because I did that song like Crazy!
I wasn't even a vampire knight girlie even.
but I'll try it.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh, it's so...
I haven't heard this song in like a decade.
Let's see how well I can do it.
I miss Alice.
I think I didn't choose Kili Kili Joker was because one of Wakeshima Kanon's...
She's a beautiful cello player, so it was mostly cello than singing, and I was like, oh my gosh, I'm gonna have to come up with like crazy choreo for it.
I miss Alice.
I'm going to use the fruit of the fruit.
I'm going to give you love.
I'm going to give you the words.
I'm going to make my words.
Still you do not answer
Oh, sorry, I forgot to change the song.
That was still dull.
Dool.
Still dull.
Oh, my gosh.
I seriously haven't heard that song in like a decade for real.
Wow.
I can't believe I remember so much of it.
Wait, that kind of makes me want to sing something else.
Hold on.
Oh, gosh.
What's it called?
I wonder.
Wait.
Oh, my gosh.
Stop reading my mind.
Minto and density.exe bringing back the 2020 10 Nico Nigo Aki Bake.
Yeah.
Even our website is like that we will have up and everything.
We were like, make, make, make it like old.
old akiba old like geocities
the only thing i remember about vampire night was the guy knowing he would live longer let her marry and live for 90 years until he died and then then be with her i remember they were cousins
that's that's what i remember
remember to oh man hold on I'm gonna drink some of my my syrup wait worse than just cousins no way I remember the betrayal way more that reminds me of like so basically in the Detective Conan Fudoshi fandom they hardcore ship Conan and Kaito kid right and then in one of the recent movies in one of the recent movies they were like by the way Chichi slash Conan and Kaito kid they're cousins they had like a meltdown
I thought they were siblings and are they were they siblings no way Wait, actually?
Do I need to watch Vampire Net?
They were cousins.
Oh, good.
Kissing cousins.
Hands.
Touching hands.
Reaching out.
Kissing cousins.
Kissing you.
I'm still eating my syrup.
Hold on.
Don't do that.
Don't kiss your cousin on the lips.
Carol Lambert wait Carol Carol Alabama so should I sing sweet home Alabama I just finished binging Macross and apparently being cousins never stop some people that I wait should we sing a Macross song um the composer for our song anita san is uh one of the composers for macros delta um let's see i want to do a frontier song sorry i should sing a macros song what do i sing though
oh my gosh there's so many i just see i like like what about my star like everything i oh it's so
how do we request a song um you can just kind of say it and sometimes i pick it but i don't always i'm not like doing request request but thank you so much i'm glad you like it thank you we could do triangle
triangle any chance you'll do colorful you know oh maybe you can
have borderline i always do you can have borderline though
not not youtube giving me dead emas dead emasu oh ronko ronko someone so cute um i could do lion maybe try and get maybe that one is
wait I don't remember if is there a bridge I don't know if I remember it though congratulations on tomorrow, Minto thank you thank you so much Matilda the musical I'm sorry I don't know I could do lion since there's like a there's already a karaoke for it.
Wait, what's how's lion go again?
Wait, how does lion start?
Oh,
now you're spamming.
The timeout you go.
Christmas songs.
We'll save that for Christmas.
I avoid the ima sukai.
I feel like I've sung that one quite a bit recently too.
Oh.
Okay, I'm gonna sing Lion.
I'm gonna try and remember.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, boom, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Wait, did I sing this one recently then?
Why is it showing that I've sung it?
I want to sing one that I don't sing often.
Oh, what?
Oh, my gosh.
This is one like that you don't hear very often.
Hopefully this is an actual instrumental.
it says it is.
I don't know what it says it is.
.
Am I, am I, am I, is my key off?
Oh my god, the lyrics they give you were bad.
They're slow!
Why the hell did I choose a song?
It's been so long, I can't even remember it.
Sorry.
I used to listen to this one a lot, so I thought that I remember it, but I don't know.
And
it all come back to me.
Hit me.
But it didn't.
Sorry.
Is this the same person?
It is.
But they're the only ones uploading these instrumentals.
Okay, hopefully this one's better.
This is so crazy.
Oh my god, I gotta look up, hold on, I gotta look up the lyrics.
Oh my gosh, they're so slow, I can't follow.
Triangular.
They're so, they're so slow to come up on the screen.
I'll start it over, sorry.
Oh my god, it's impossible to follow.
Okay.
There we go.
Sorry.
Sorry about that.
I was trying.
Fix your thing.
Actually, wait.
Let me see if there's, like, a better quality version if I'm not even going to follow the...
Wait, try.
Karo-ke.
Torae...
Angul...
Is this right?
Oh, it's Angulah.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, is this right?
Hold on.
One second.
I'm checking.
Oh, oh, nice, nice, nice.
I found one.
Okay, I found one.
Okay, sorry.
Okay.
It's got a cool, funky intro too.
It's a straight line If it's not true If it's not true It's true If it's true Who's it?
Who's it?
I'm sorry But that's true That's true The world's more You're more than The more than
Hi baby!
Morsow, sabbath, obi-chick And I'm back, I'm back, I'm back, I'm back, I'm looking down I'm thinking, I'm back,
I'm back, I'm gonna get it.
It's a pain.
My mucinous My nukin' No one can hear you I'm laughing, I'm gonna see you I'm gonna see you I'm gonna see you Now, soon On me Lisei N'est thing Oh, she's down
Oh, is there a bridge?
I don't know if I remember it.
If you
are the only one who will kiss me?
Who
will the other kiss me?
I, or that girl?
Just one life's life's life.
I'm just going to give you the same thing.
Oh,
I also forgot to change it again, I'm sorry.
Tri-Tra-Train.
Tri-Train.
Tri-angler.
Yay!
Oh my gosh, such a classic.
A real classic.
A classic.
Tri-angler.
I want to try it.
Triangler.
It's triangular, guys.
Duh.
Triangler.
No, no.
I spelled it correctly.
Triangler.
What is there?
Is there another?
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
I kind of want to sing Seikahiko because of Phoebe.
You know what?
I will.
Let's see.
There's gotta be a...
Northern Cross.
How does that song go?
Seikahiko!
.
Yeah Yeah
See men go You like the wind The wind The wind
Flared at your Just look at Just look at the Just look
No, no, no, no, no, We, When we see our N'ONABY Like the MAKORO The light of the HANAZU JURU-ZURU-ZU- Yeah Hira
JURU-ZURU-ZU-ZU-ZU-UZUZUZUZU- The
city On the other side
Oh, oh Keshit's a blue No, no Mata'atak Tate T'wasi Niggen The Naga-deck Seine Mata-a-get You are the gutter Oh, oh No, no No, no Hoshi Sola'i What's our Hanna-bee Like I believe you can see the light of light.
I believe you.
I believe you know it's still.
My soul, my soul, my soul, my soul, my love is flowing.
Hi, baby.
You sing, Macross, Frontier, and Phoebe will appear.
Say Macross, say Macross three times in the mirror fast.
Macross, Macross, Macross, Macross, Macross, and Phoebe will appear.
Yay!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
You summoned me!
Yeah!
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
One second.
Okay.
You guys, I got, like, the cutest email today.
I got the cutest email today.
And it was just like, hello.
We are from high school.
Would you like to be a guest speaker for my e-sports, for our e-sports class?
And of course I'm going to do it.
But they were like, it's kind of an urgent matter.
But they didn't tell me when.
Of course I'm going to accept.
And then they were like, here's the address to the school.
If you cannot show up, you can Zoom call.
It was...
So if you are listening Esports class of of that school which I will not say any at all of course I will join your your class I will zoom in I will zoom call in Do you know anything by Peramore?
Oh too high!
I don't know, let's see
Oh, I'm not an esports student.
I've never done esports, that's a lie.
I've done esports once.
I've barely, I've done like one tournament before.
I'm not, I don't know why I'm being invited to the esports class.
I didn't even know, high schools had an esports class.
I'm excited to hear what you have to say about esports.
They're probably gonna be like, how did you become a streamer?
And I'm gonna be like, luck baby.
It's all about...
They're not going to like that answer, though, huh?
Work hard.
And, uh...
You know.
I kind of know Ain't It Fun.
But only a little bit.
I could try it.
Why not?
I like singing new stuff.
I don't want to always sing the same songs that I do, you know?
Ain't It...
fun.
Let's try it.
I don't mind.
Let you down easy, but just give me time.
If it don't hurt now, then just wait a while.
Oh, am I singing this right?
No more.
What they're beating on.
So what are you gonna do around you you you so what are you gonna do when the world don't orbit around you sounds good okay ain't it fun living in the real world ain't it good being all alone
Where you're from, from, oh, you might be the one who's running things.
Well, you can't ring any bell that's good to watch you ride, nor trouble.
Gonna do when the world don't orbit around you.
Uh-oh, so what are you gonna do when nobody wants to fool with you?
Ain't it fun Living in the real world Bada bam, bada bam Ain't it good Being all alone Ain't it good to be on your own Ain't it fun you can't count on no one Ain't it good to be on your own Can't count on no one.
Ain't it fun living in the real world?
Hidda bam, hidda bam.
Don't go crying to your mama Cause you're on your own in the real world.
Oh, I was early.
Don't go crying to your mama Cause you're on your own in the real world Stop go crying to your mama Cause you're on your own in the real world Ain't it fun, ain't it fun, baby now you're one of us Ain't it fun, ain't it fun, ain't it fun And in the real world Ain't it good Being all alone And in
the real world All the world don't orbit around you Do it good?
Oh, I don't know this part Ah!
All alone
again to your mom, to your mother.
You're out in the real world.
To your mom, because you're on your own in the real world.
Someone in the background is like really loud.
Because you're on your own.
In the real world, don't go crying Because you're on your own in the real world This is the real world To your mama Because you're on your own in the real
Because you're on your own in the real world Oh, ah, ah, ah, ah Don't go crying to your mama Cause you're on your own In the real world
Yay I don't know that song like I don't, she has so many Adlips at the end, I was like I don't know like any of these
That's fine That's fine Yay This kind of makes me Let's see, uh
Did I spell it wrong?
What do you mean there's no results for my chemical romance?
What the?
What do you mean?
Huh?
Be!
That's like not possible.
Really?
try mcr did they rebrand no i get tate mcray i don't know who that is no way that's craziness but that's okay i want to do some you know what i say i don't want to sing all the same songs all the time but there are some that i do want to sing that are some of the ones that i like
we'll do this one i know you guys will like
emo isn't real mint no it wasn't a phase it wasn't a phase
if there's a prize for rotten judgment i guess i've already won that.
No man is worth the aggravation.
That's ancient history.
Been there, done that.
Who you think you're kidding?
He's the earth and heaven till you try to keep it hidden.
Honey, we can see right now.
No chance, no way.
I won't say it.
No, no.
You swoon, you sigh, why deny it, oh It's too cliche, I won't say I'm in love I thought my heart had learned its lesson It feels so good when you start out My head is screaming, get a grip, girl Unless you're dying to cry your heart out
Oh no!
No chance, no way, I won't say it no, no Give up, give it Check the grin, you're in love The scene won't play, I won't say I'm in love You do, we don't have to start in love Your way, your face, I won't say it off my case i won't say yeah girl don't be proud it's okay
at least out loud i won't say i'm in love
do you like my acting
zero the hero i don't know if i've ever done that one before He was a zero, zero, zero.
Now he's a hero.
Okay, I might mess this up.
Let's try it.
Bless my soul.
Herc was on a roll.
Person of the week in every Greek opinion poll.
What a pro.
Herc could stop a show.
Point him at a monster and you're talking SRO.
Here was a no one.
A zero, zero.
Now he's a honcho.
He's a hero.
Here was a kid with his act down pat.
From zero to hero, in no time flat, Zero to hero, just like that.
When you smile, the girls went wild with ooze and eyes.
And they slapped his face on every vase, on every of us.
For appearance fees and royalties, our herd had cash to burn.
From no guru rich or famous, he could tell you what the Grecians are.
Amen, there he goes again.
Sorry, I don't defeat it at an awesome 10 for 10.
Folks lined up just to watch it flex.
This perfect package with a pair of pretty pecs.
Herky he comes, he sees he conquers.
Honey the crowns were going balkers.
I don't know this part at all.
Zero to hero, a major hunt.
Zero to hero, and who to thug?
Who won't the gladden?
Gladiator, Hercules, who daring deeds are great theater.
Hercules, is he bold?
Is he sweet?
Hercules, Hercules, Hercules.
Hercules, I don't know.
Hercules, Hercules, this my soul, Hercules was on a roll, undefeated feeling, riding high and the nicest guy, conceited he was a nothing now he's a honcho he's a hero he's a hero oh from zero to hero freak is a hero now he's a hero
yes indeed oh my god why why why oh geez
i'm out of water
Are we just going to sing all Hercules songs?
Oops, all Hercules.
I want to sing other dance.
Out there from Hunchback.
I'm scared.
I have trauma with that song.
And my voice is starting to give out a little bit, so I'm like, well, I'd be able to hit the notes.
Oh, God.
Hold on.
Let me get some more water.
Oh, wait.
Actually, hold on.
I can...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, no, no.
My throat spray.
I do not know build me up buttercup I'm sorry okay I think out there might be my final song if that's okay guys because my voice starting to get a little scratchy so and I want to sing tomorrow too basically oh my gosh you guys don't even oh oh every every oh my gosh I'll be like okay I got to one extra thing I have to record like I'll be like okay I'm gonna put away my I'm gonna put away my recording stuff later and then I have to pull it all back out to record oh I pull it back out to record put so many times so many times I've been like I have to record this I have to record this uh yesterday I recorded like two three songs or something like I've been recording like
No!
And I have to record more Saturday.
I have to record two more songs Saturday.
So it's been like it's been just non-stop recording for me.
Because some stuff will be like extra takes for like the original song.
Or like they'll need extra stuff.
Or will We have some other things that we will be showing off tomorrow and the day after.
So, the original song will be on Saturday, by the way.
So, make sure you watch the group collab so that you can catch the original song.
But, yeah, so it's like, so we have stuff that we're still down to the wire finishing up, but it's just been like, mad.
It's been, it's been, yeah, and I'll be like, okay, back to recording.
Take a break to eat.
Back to recording.
Take another break or something.
Get back to the recording.
So much recording.
So much.
So, so, hmm.
Hopefully there's a, hopefully, hopefully it's all worth it.
Hopefully you guys like everything.
Yeah, yeah.
You're at a wedding this weekend.
You should tell the DJ.
DJ to play Den Setsu MVPs.
Be like, DJ, put this on.
It's the hottest song right now.
So, yeah.
I'm very excited, obviously, about everything.
I, you know, I didn't expect some people's reactions to it.
was really happy you know that so many people were um were really excited for us but i think you know there are some people that are kind of nervous because of um because of uh you know we've had a couple setbacks i've had a couple setbacks in the past um but i want to kind of
a lot of planning went into this um and i if if we weren't so sure about it like we wouldn't have gone through with it and um you know i had i i was on i remember being in my hotel room and i i was like seeing people's responses i was like whoa and it makes sense because to us we understand what's going on and to you guys you're probably just like what is this what is happening what is going on um so uh it probably seems like a little more obviously it's official but like a little more how to say like because we're not corporate so it probably see it might seem that way but you know we still all own our ips and everything um we uh we're very much still you know even i think you know you know like if even if setzuna were to pull out we would still be den setzu if we wanted to be so yeah like i know that some people are quite weary about corporal corporations and everything right now um but but well like i said we were we um satsuna has been really great with us and uh so far and um
things won't change for my content at all um except just adding more stuff for you guys so uh so yeah i just wanted to like i i was like having an anxiety attack at the hotel room i was like because i don't know i just didn't expect to us you know obviously we know what's going on and then so i was like oh my gosh i didn't expect people's reactions and i was like wow wow it just it threw me through a loop but um yeah so uh we're we're very confident that you know that things will be awesome and we're excited for everything so we just want to take you guys along on the journey so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah not and you know well yeah i was gonna say something and then i lost the i had the the second part of the thought and i did not have the first part of the thought and thank you guys so much for the donos i do see them thank you thank you thank you magical circle guru guru i'm sorry i don't know
I guess, uh, you know, it kind of came out of nowhere and I guess it's appeared different than how it actually is.
So, um, you know, uh, maybe, maybe if we look like we're corporate, that means we have our stuff together because behind the scenes, we're kind of scrambling.
It looks like we, we look so official that we look like we could be corporate, but, but behind the scenes, we're like, we're like scrambling little ants or all.
over the place.
Can't be trolled.
Thank you so much, brother.
Happy to see you three get the debut as idols.
Can't wait to support you along with everyone else.
MVP, yeah.
It'll be the first idol group I follow.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Can't wait to see where you go with the Institute.
Thank you.
Yeah, so it still feels bizarre to me, even.
It still feels very strange.
A lot of this stuff a lot of the stuff was well not a lot there was a handful of things that were being prepared a long long time ago and then kind of everything got thrown into a blender and so we had to kind of to kind of throw up pick up the pieces and try to puzzle them back together and see what we can salvage and what we could still use and we oh man you know I love I'm really happy with our song so much i love um the work that anita san has done we did have another artist that i was so excited to work with um maybe hopefully we can still work with them one day it was like a dream artist of mine so i was like oh i was i was like unfortunately it didn't work out but i honestly i don't even mind because the song is just that it's just that so it's just that good i can't wait you guys to hear it oh i can't wait for you guys to hear it it's so it makes your heart go go and then and then and so it's a fun song it's so fun it's so fun this will be the first underground idol group i
follow yeah oh my gosh you can hear it in my voice oh geez will i be able to sing this song i wonder i'll do my best let me do another throat spray cover
cover with nimi thank you now whenever i hear on my own i'm going to think of epony and longing for solace no it's me it's me
okay this will be probably my last song i know i wanted to actually sing much longer i don't even know how many songs i've done
you and I'll sing some more tomorrow just a couple songs though just a couple it sounds exactly like something you'd produce just all kinds of whoosh and wah yeah whoosh and wah woosh and wah yeah so okay last song last song save your voice for tomorrow no no no it's okay it's okay I just,
I am okay.
I just don't know if I'll hit the note because we'll see.
We'll see, we'll see.
Let's try.
I'm stronger now.
Connection lost.
Wait, what?
What do you mean by that?
Am I still streaming?
Am I still live?
Wait, what do you mean connection lost?
I am?
Oh, maybe...
Hold on, let me see.
Let me open Carol find up again.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, it's just starting.
Okay, let's go!
Safe behind these windows and these parapets of stone Gazing at the people down below me.
All my life I watch them as I hide up here alone.
They show me All my life I memorize their faces Knowing them as they will never know me All my life I wonder how it feels to pass a day Not above them But part of them And out there Living in the sun one day out there all I ask is one to hold forever how there where they all live unaware what I'd give what I dare just to live one day out there
Out there among the millers and the weavers and their wives Through the roofs and gables I can see them Every day they shout and scold and go about their lives Needless of the gift it is to be them If I was in their skin a treasure Every instant out there Strolling by the sand Taste a morning out there Like ordinary men Who freely walk up out there Just one day and then I swear I'll be content With my share Won't present despair.
Hold that bent.
I won't care.
All has meant for us.
Now there.
I can't hit that damn note.
I can't do it.
I can't hit that sticker.
No.
It haunts me.
That stupid-ass note.
Thank you guys.
Almost there.
No, that's not the name of the song.
The song is called Out There.
Oh, the trauma of the song.
Ah, we'll do it.
We'll do it.
I'll do it better next time.
Whatever.
It's such a high note.
It is.
It's like a knot in my...
I could hit it if I don't use my head voice.
You know?
Like I use...
Like the way I sing the song.
song like you know it's very easy if I sing with my chest chest voice but with my head voice it's like so high and then I always forget to switch so oh well whatever I give up I give up it's not like I'm gonna be it's not like I'm gonna be singing is that like it's not like I have a group to on me or anything for my voice.
It's not like it's not like I'm gonna be doing concerts or
it's not like it's not like it's my job.
Okay, wait.
I want to do one more.
I want to do one that I can end on that sounds good.
What's a what?
What's a song that I could sing?
What's a song I don't know how the end of my brain is.
My brain is braining?
Killy Killy Joker.
I literally said I didn't learn it.
Shut up.
I'm going to put you in timeout.
It's also mostly...
It's mostly cello.
A Love Live A Love Live song Love Live What's a Love Live song?
I scream Scream Scream I show
Wait You guys I think I have to sing this song Given the Given Given our location
I've seen it.
I've been there at the time from the feeling of a loud and loud heart melody I've been able to stop it, I've been able to stop it.
Why?
I've been there for years.
Why do I feel the sadness and the name of the song?
The narration Oh boy, I can't stand to wait for it.
It's a bit too much, but I love it and I love it.
In the heat of the night, I can't even think about it.
I'm going to be able to give it some time.
I'm going to start.
There's no sound, there's no sound.
Climb boxes
Lie high
Where are you going
Fly high I just
remember something.
Oh, Shook.
I wish I was ancient history, I'll have a great time
Yay!
That reminds me that...
I'm glad I have a manager now because I don't respond to emails sometimes.
I get busy.
Yeah.
Otomito everybody!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
I might have gotten an email from certain someone who likes a girl and a baby.
I don't know!
Cypher!
Happy birthday.
Happy bladed birthday.
Tomorrow, Densutsu.exe, I'll see you there!
See you there, see you there, see you there.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, you better be there, you better be there, all of you,
every single one of you.
of you.
Bye-bye.